الى جنيف الان ينضم اليه لمزيد من
المتابعه المدير العام للجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر روبير مارتيني اهلا وسهلا
بك يعني الصوره مبكيه مفجعه ولكن مع ذلك
ساسالك اي تقييم يعطيه الصليب الاحمر
للوضع في اليوم الخامس من هذا الزلزال
الذي ضرب مناطق شرق المتوسط وهل الصوره
ماساويه تماما ام لا ثمت بارقه امل من
وصول المساعدات في الوقت المحدد الى
محتاجينها
الوضع ماساوي جدا ونحن باللهجه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر نتعاطف مع جميع السوريين
اليوم
يجب ان لا ننسى ان جميع السكان في سوريا
الاخرى على مدار اكثر من عقد وصولا الى
اللحظه الراهنه من نزاع تسبب في تبعات
انسانيه كارثيه الى جائحه الكوفيد 19
وازمه اقتصاديه طاحنه تفشي وباء الكوليرا
اخر سنه السنه والان كارثه طبيعيه مع هذا
الزلزال التي تقع في الحقيقه ظروف مناخيه
قاسيه جدا وحتى قبل وقوع الزلزال هذا
الاسبوع عدى النزاع في سوريا الى اقتراب
البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه والخدمات العامه
في ارجاء البلاد الى نقطه انهيار وهذا هذا
هذا هذه مشكله كبيره وهو وضع يتطلب اصلا
المزيد من المساعدات من الجهات الانسانيه
ما الذي تفعلونه الان وحجم الاستجابه
لنداءاتكم لتقديم المساعده سواء من الدول
او المنظمات
اللجنه الدوليه تتواجد في سوريا منذ 12
سنه بشده تعمل يد باليد مع المتطوعين
الهلال الاحمر السوري واستجابه اللجنه
الدوليه لصليب الاحمر فورا للاحتياجات
الانسانيه الاشد الحاحا وشمل ذلك تلبيه
الاحتياجات الطبيه حيث تعمل الان فرق
متعدده على الارض لتقييم الاوضاع واعداد
عمليه استجابه قويه مع تدفق المساعدات الى
سوريا التي هي تتواجد عنا والمزيد من
المساعدات تصل الى سوريا
ومن الاهميه بما كان ونحن نشهد فصول هذه
الاحداث الماساويه ان لا ننسى محنه السكان
في عموم البلاد فالاحتياجات تتزايد في ظل
نقص التمويل المتخصص للمساعدات وللاسف طيب
ما الذي يحتاجه المتضررون الان وبشكل
العاجل وفي حال تامنت المساعدات متضامن
بانها ستصل الى المستحقين يا استاذ روبير
نحن نعرف انه ما زالت في مناطق يعني بتعرف
في حرب اهليه في سوريا استمرت عشر سنوات
في مناطق خاضعه للحكومه في مناطق خاضعه
للمعارضه انتم تستطيعون العمل في المنطقه
بنفس الشروط وفي تسهيل من الجميع لمهمتكم
ام لا في مناطق من الصعوبه ان تعملوا فيها
بالفعل ونحن سنمد يد العون لكل من يحتاج
الى المساعده حيثما كان واينما وجد اما
بشان الوصول المساعدات فيجب الا توضع اي
عراقيه امام وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
واوضحنا ذلك لجميع الاطراف
على مدى سنوات النزاع اللي تفضلت وذاكرته
ونكرر دعوتنا اليوم ويجب ان تمنح
اللجنه الدوليه
وتمنح الدوله السوريه والجماعات المسلحه
الاولويه للاحتياجات الانسانيه الهائله
وندعوهم الى وضع القضايا السياسيه جانبا
هل تمت اطراف تعرق الوصول للمساعدات وفق
معلوماتك
نحن نعمل عشاء
بمنطقه ادلب مع الاطراف المعنيه في تحديات
ولكن نعمل ونتامل انه
القضايا السياسيه حتوضع جنبا والاولويه
الانسانيه حتكون
هل لديكم
سواء مع الحكومه السوريه ومع مقاتلي
المعارضه لتسهيل مهمتكم ام لا في بعض
الامكنه الاتصالات مقطوعه وان كنت اسالك
اسئله تفصيليه لا ولكن المشاهد يريد ان
يعرف خصوصا عملكم في المناطق التي هي
خاضعه الى حد ما لسيطره مقاتلي المعارضه
نريد ان نعرف كيف تتحركون هناك اللجنه
الدوليه على على اتصال مع جميع الاطراف
اليوم الاتصال مع المعارضه في ادلب نواجه
بعض التحديات ولكن نتامل انه هالاتصال
حيكون حيكون ايجابي وحيسمح لنا نوصل ونؤدي
الاستجابه الانسانيه طيب
انا سانقل لك المشهد وانت اكيد عم بتابع
يعني المشهد مهول مفجع مبكي شاهدنا في
اطفال فقدوا ذويهم حتى اقاربهم طب هؤلاء
مش بس بلا ماوى يعني من يرعاهم في ناس
يهمون على وجوههم
طيب هؤلاء انا اتحدث فقط عن الاطفال طيب
هؤلاء كيف يتم
ان يحتضنهم احد ان يرعاهم احد خصوصا في
هذه الفتره هل لديكم اي داله على ذلك
الحاله مبكيه
وصعبه للغايه يعني ما ننسى انه كمان
يجد عدد كبير من المفقودين من النزاع
ونعرف هالشي باللجنه الدوليه لصليب الاحمر
فبالنسبه للاطفال اكيد المجتمعات هي اللي
استجابت باول ساعات النزاع واكيد نحن هلا
دورنا انه مع الهلال الاحمر السوري مساعده
النازحين اللي زاد عددهم قبل الزلزال كان
في سبعه مليون نازح بسوريا وهلا اكيد عدد
النازحين مع هالزلزال والكارثه يزداد
واكيد الاستجابه الانسانيه لازم تحط
كاولويه المساعده الاطفال
والسيجروبير كمان في كمان في موضوع هو
مساله المياه يعني كانت تفشل كوليرا في
عدد من المناطق في سوريا في السنه في
السنه الماضيه الان مع هذا الزلزال وعدم
توفر مياه نظيفه خصوصا وكذلك مياه الشفا
في مخاطر من عوده الكوليرا ان يضرب مجددا
تحديدا الاطفال هون هل لديكم اي معلومات
اكيد نحن بنعرف انه 50% من امدادات المياه
والصرف الصحي
لا تعمل على نحو جيد وهذا الشيء قبل
الزلزال فاليوم اكيد التحديات بالنسبه
للمياه
والصرف الصحي تحديات بعد اكبر وكل العمل
يلي قامت فيه اللجنه الدوليه والهلال
الاحمر السوري خلال هذه السنين لازم نعززه
اكثر
لتفادي تفشي الكوليرا اللي هو اكيد
خطر خطر قوي جدا حاليا طيب وانت تتحدث
الحكومه السوريه تقول انه تم السماح
لمساعدات لدخول مساعدات انسانيه لمناطق
المعارضه بالتنسيق مع الصليب الاحمر
الدولي هل يمكن تاكيد هذه المعلومات
نحن على اتصال وفي عنا امدادات صحيه عم
توصل على سوريا وعم نوزعها الاماكن مثل
مثل حلب اللاذقيه طرطوس وفرحنا على الارض
عم تعمل حاليا من جناب المدير العام للجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر روبير مارديني شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه